[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys and
welcome back to the leia hile plan show
we are quite a few episodes in now so
i'm really excited
we have a really cool guest today but
before we do want to say a quick thank
you and a quick
shout out so this is powered by icon um
iconplus
are i'm super excited to announce that
it will be integrated into orbit bridge
developed by orbit chain
bringing many ethereum assets to the
icon project and bridging top
blockchains including icon
clayton ethereum and terra i also want
to say a quick thank you
to my sponsors blockbuy um so i do use
them
i an update 8.6 interest on my usdc
um an announcement actually came out
today about the bank of england they're
offering i think it's 0.01
interest so if 8.6 percent interest
sounds great to you
and then i'll leave the link below you
can get 250
when you sign up and before i bring on
my really exciting guest
um another quick shout out to coinflip
so they're doing some incredible work
across the states
to push bitcoin mass adoption they now
have 1 200 bitcoin atms
um so i'm going to leave a code below as
well you can get 10 off that
so joining me today is crypto trader
advisor
xdj and music producer it is scott
melka how are you doing i'm great how
are you thank you so much for
for having me on yeah it's great to have
you
i've seen all you know i'm watching your
tweets and watching your content
and it's good just to speak to the
person directly
it's been pretty crazy um you know the
last couple of days and
i will talk about bitcoin um but i kind
of want to learn a little bit more about
you
understand wolf of all streets where
that came from
um but i want to go back to the music
because
you were a music producer and a dj so
what happened why are you not doing that
anymore
i age you know i i just kind of uh aged
out to be honest
i don't know if you've ever seen the
movie dazed and confused but matthew
mcconaughey he has a
famous character and a famous line in
that movie and he says talk about high
school girls and he says
i get older they stay the same age well
that's how i felt about djing i kept
getting older but the people i was djing
to
never got any older right and so at one
point i was like in my mid to late
30s my wife was at home with my daughter
and i was out traveling and playing
shows
at like fraternity houses and like 20
year old kids were trying to get me
drunk and all i wanted to do was go home
and face time with my daughter and it's
just
you know kind of a unsustainable there
are people who can do it
um and listen there's amazing djs who
are in their 60s
50s 60s who have been doing it but
that's a very select group that sort of
i think
live for that lifestyle so
partially it was i guess uh choice and
partially i mean i just
slowly became less passionate about it
and and less relevant i mean to be
to be quite honest like if you're not
passionate about it at that age there's
always a
20 year old killer dj who's like coming
to take the title you know what i mean
so um and it coincided very well with my
sort of discovery of crypto i was
already trading and love trading and
so i just it's kind of my nature to
become extremely focused on singular
things
which is weird i have adhd but that can
sometimes manifest in hyper focus
on certain things um and ignoring
everything else and that became crypto
for me
it just sort of went from there yeah
that's cool i mean i like to hear
um you know some people talk about adhd
like it's a bit of a nightmare
when it comes to you know just getting
on and stuff but that's really cool
to hear you know it made you focus on
one thing i guess priorities just change
don't they
yeah it's just life you know like yeah i
i
um everybody always kind of thought i
was nuts
in all of my life decisions throughout
you know
i went to an ivy league university and
then passed on wall street to
dj and i started like four failed or
moderately successful companies
during that time it was always some
crazy whimsical idea
i don't know i just you know my
priorities sort of shift with the wind
or like i said with what i'm feeling
particularly passionate about at a time
but there does come a certain age where
um well it's not even age it's having
kids and having a family like you can't
really
focus purely on yourself i was very
selfish you know in my pursuits and
everything
that was a very big struggle to to get
there mentally but
once you have kids and you see how
important it is to spend time with them
everything changes i mean everything you
makes
okay so family is obviously huge for you
i think that's one of the most adorable
things on your feed to be honest i'm
always seeing your kids and you know
your relationship with your wife on
twitter
um twitter is full of trolls and
crypto twitter particularly um you know
it can be quite dangerous
right so i'm just interested how come
you're comfortable
putting your family uh i mean i guess
your wife's already on twitter but like
you're showing your kids because a lot
of people
don't even put their names out there you
know
i get that question all the time so one
is that
i was doing it before i was involved in
crypto
so to be to some degree there was no
putting the cap back in the bag like i
uh
i never was pursuing a career in crypto
as a influencer or whatever like i was
just a dude with some followers for
music who started talking about crypto
right and so for whatever reason it
built but it was never like a business
decision ever so i just always sort of
behaved as i always did
um and i believe and it's not to
begrudge anyone who is anonymous because
i
am jealous of them at times i wish that
i could just go about my life in that
manner
and it is dangerous as you said like
some of the stories i could share are
pretty nuts
um hacks and threats and things like
that
but at the end of the day like i feel
like somebody has to
do it like some and i'm not saying like
i'm some great example or anything but
somebody has to be out there
showing what real life looks like um
and so yeah like i over share i get a
lot of uh
comments on that i don't think i'm
putting my children in danger if
in danger if i legit legitimately did i
wouldn't do it
but i i was a public figure to some
degree before
and i always have been so like there's
no hiding my
personal information anymore you know
it's just
it's it's not going to happen so there
are a lot of advantages to being docs
and being yourself as you know right i
mean you probably wouldn't have icon
block fi and coin flip listed on the
bottom of this if you were a uh
cartoon unicorn you know
uh yeah and as this space grows
um there will be you know more
tremendous opportunities i think for
people who are showing their faces and
whatever
the i think the irony of the whole thing
is because i show my face i get called a
fake
more often than people who don't i know
it's so funny isn't it
yeah i mean yeah like you you make some
interesting points i think i'm actually
i can totally relate because
i was online before crypto um you know
especially because
i'm a millennial so i'm in my 20s so
you know i guess growing up as a
teenager like there are pictures of me
as a baby in my dad's arms on myspace
so no one go look for that um
don't do that but yeah there are
pictures there and i guess you can't
really
you can't really do much about it at
that point but i think you're right you
know when you say somebody has to do it
like how is this thing going to go
mainstream
if we're all just hiding behind avatars
you know for you to
for somebody to rely and like trust in
something there needs to be a level of
accountability
and you don't have that if we're all
anonymous
yeah and listen when i was younger a i
was a bit of a troll myself
um just in the dj community it was very
similar like a lot of competition that
guy sucks that guy's not even djing he's
fake
like all that you know it kind of echoed
the same thing and i was definitely like
a loud mouth
sort of there i was less mature um
but like so i'm kind of the trolling
thing doesn't bother me i actually
like every time somebody tries to troll
me i like giggle on the inside and i
share it with my friends
i'm sure you've seen me reading my dms
you know like i just thought that was so
good
because like i just need to do that i
mean these people don't know me you know
what i mean like that
and i'm i feel like i'm being
transparent but like
haters are gonna hate you know and it's
fine and and if it
sort of propels helps propel the space
forward doing my small part i'm more
than happy to like
take the abuse of a few uh cartoons
you know but like you said it does it
does sometimes verge on
uncomfortable territory like sim
swappings and
being targeted for hacks and i've had
people you know
send me personal photos they shouldn't
have had of yeah
in my own town so like as if they were
like watching us you know things like
that so
wow that's all very strange but um
you know yeah that's pretty yeah that's
pretty insane
i mean you're obviously much bigger than
i am i've not experienced that the only
thing i
experienced it wasn't which wasn't off
it was just kind of like a weird
thing i was in romania um and i was
walking
and um some guy just comes straight up
to me he's like you're layer and i'm
like
oh yeah yeah that's just cool yeah yeah
that's just cool though
i think it's nice yeah yeah it was good
i don't know how either i had like no
makeup on and my glasses on so i was
just like oh clearly i look the same
thank you
yeah exactly flattered without my pokers
literally um but you tweeted yesterday
which i thought was really interesting
that this year
has changed your opinion on a lot from
like politics to money
um tell me about that i'm so fascinated
by that
um yeah i think that uh
a lifetime of experience sort of
implants
ideas in your head right you start um
as a child and all of your core beliefs
or the beliefs of your parents
or your community or whatever you're
immediately surrounded with right
see it religion nationalism all these
things if
if like i was raised jewish right and
but if i had been born in iran
and i was raised my whole life view
would be different and
of no doing of my own right just where i
landed and what i was surrounded by
so you know then you kind of grow up you
go to college you get
like maybe more exposure another life
view and then through life
i think you just sort of evolve and
even in my 20s and 30s i think i was
very stuck in
like sort of value systems that i just
assumed were right or whatever and i
think you really start thinking for
yourself in your 30s and then you start
to get you know yourself in your 40s and
then you totally know yourself
apparently according to oprah in your
50s
i even tweeted yesterday maybe yesterday
i was like you know basically anything
you think you probably believe in your
20s you'll
like shake your head at in your 40s like
my 20 year old self would troll my 40
year old self and my 40 year old self
would go choke my 20 year old self you
know what i mean
um but this year has been a great
accelerator for a lot of things
obviously we're all in the bitcoin space
we all understand that but like
i understood that fiat was a scam
obviously you know i'm into bitcoin but
seeing how the world and central banks
and monetary policy was crafted
after covid started if you couldn't
change your opinion fundamentally like
even if you had some hope or you
figured hey i have some trust in the
system like my government will take care
of me
please right so um
and so 2020 was interesting i think in
that regard but then we also had the
election
right with like probably the most
polarizing president or a
candidate in history regardless of your
feelings on him
as a candidate or as a as a person like
i have a lot of stories like i went to
school with trump jr i've
i they're one of the first one of the
first times i went viral
unfortunately was because of that a
story i shared about them at the last
election
i don't if you think i had to hide from
people on crypto twitter you should have
seen me hiding from trump supporters in
uh in 2016.
um but um
but you know that if you hate one
candidate sort of pushes you towards the
other but then one day i think you take
the red pill and realize
them all um and that's sort of
sorry i don't know if i can say that in
the show but um and that's sort of
that was sort of 2020 for me you know um
i grew up you know as a democrat like i
was you know
my parents marched on washington and
went to woodstock and were hippies but
then they became
you know more moderate as they aged like
anyone else there's that famous quote uh
if you're in your 20s like if you're not
liberal you have no heart if you're in
your 40s and you're not concerned maybe
you have no brain
right so but now i think you find
yourself in the middle and then
eventually you just quit
altogether and i i think i'm kind of
sort of at the ladder you know i view
bitcoin and what we're doing as a way to
opt out
i view it as true freedom and i i don't
think that um
any of these people can represent me or
my beliefs
yeah i mean you make so many points
there you know in terms of like
okay so your parents were democrats yes
if you don't have
if you if if you're not a democrat when
you're young you don't have a heart if
you
the other way you don't have a brain
right but i mean like things have become
far more polarized anyway so i imagine
you know
even if they kept their views you
probably find that a lot more moderate
and center anyway
just because things have become
absolutely normal
like i i still make the argument that
probably 90 i'm only speaking for the
united states but probably true
everywhere
i believe that 90 okay called 80 of the
people here
are just middle of the road and
if they actually sat down to think about
their beliefs
they would find their middle of the road
but most of them are just in this sort
of like
zombie like mass media state of
believing whatever
you know the news station they watch has
been
pounding into their brain indefinitely
over time you know um
i think most people don't really think
for themselves but once they do i think
you'll find that hey some of the stuff
those guys say is really true
and some of the stuff these guys say is
really true and i have my mixed basket
of beliefs and emotions and i'm me right
and i don't have to be
either of them but i will say one other
thing that was huge in 2020 because of
the fiscal policy and the monetary
policy and the way that we've seen
now both parties react is that
there is no more fiscal responsibility
in government on either side you know
like republicans used to claim
they were the fiscal fiscally
responsible party that was reagan you
know like reagan and bush
but then clinton balanced the budget
right but then since then it's been
money printing money printing has no
party
money printing has no politics and money
printing is what's destroying people's
lives
forget all the like things that they're
all the wagging the dog and all the
distractions all things you're looking
at at the core of it all
is the fact that you're not making more
money and your money's worth less
and that's what's destroying people's
lives yeah you make an
insane point on that you're gonna touch
on that it's exactly the same in the uk
so we have the conservative party in
right now
and we're all just like can you bring
back the conservative party like i feel
like we have a left-wing
government in right just because
naturally those are kind of the
socialist policies that you'd imagine
seeing
not necessarily money printing but yeah
you follow me um so
that's exactly what we're saying what
we're seeing here and
i'm also feeling really apolitical um
so in terms of bitcoin then what was it
that kind of what was that orange pill
like orange peel red pill moment that
got you into it was it
the underlying because i know that we
say it's apolitical but
in my opinion i often find it kind of is
political
just because it's all about like being
left alone right and that tends to be a
libertarian um i don't say right wing
because that also means something else
these
names are all jumbled up but yeah for me
it's political what about you
i think it's very fair to say that it's
political i just can't assign it to
either party and i think
that's a important distinction so like
yes it's political
absolutely but i think it's sort of a
way to rage against the machine
of politics itself right so to to
be a political in itself is political to
some degree right because you would
prefer that there was
a a party or a politician who still
represented you
you just can't find one that does and
that's why you're sort of a political
right
so that's one bitcoin i came for the
money not for the bitcoin like
i was trading you know what i mean and
there's this like mythical land of 100x
all coin pumps happening and my friends
were getting into it and telling me
about it you know and
i came for that and i sort of like you
know backed into i guess the importance
of
actual bitcoin even until last year and
listen
like i get trolled constantly for like
i used to say
but guess what i've changed my opinion
i've changed my opinion and i'm not
deleting it
you know like go back and find it i'll
i'll answer for it it's fine
but like even a year ago i was like
aggressively like five percent of your
money
maybe 10 if you're crazy in crypto this
is volatile like it could whatever and
this year it's like
i ain't rebalancing i'm riding this
thing as far as i can ride it because
it's important so
i used to be in it to make dollars
because i would make the point i can't
pay my kids private school tuition and
my mortgage now i want more bitcoin like
genuinely
you know and so i think for me the real
big aha moment still happened
this year i think there were seeds of it
last year and listen if you were here in
16 or 17 which kind of when i started
like i really got into it in early 2017.
and you rode the bear market like with
it and you still had a passion for it
then you certainly had some belief in it
but like
now you're seeing all the things that
you were called crazy for
actually play out i talked to jamison
lop i don't know if you know him if you
don't you should have him on the show
you know when the original cypherpunks
and whatever and that was what he said
he's like i don't even give a that
the price has gone up so crazy i'm just
happy that
nobody's calling me crazy anymore and i
can laugh at all these people after 10
years you know and
it's it really there is some uh there is
some like satisfaction i guess
in that yeah no absolutely i mean i'm
seeing like i told you so tweets
um and all this stuff but i think that's
really interesting because you've said
you know you've been here since like
2016 2017 but it was really
this year that just sort of i guess kind
of like
brought everything to a crescendo and
you were really able to sort of
see that value that true yeah
yeah i think i just got really so
disgusted with everything this year
yeah the great answer for being
disgusted with everything
it really is yeah so this is an
interesting topic which i want to get
into
um because people look at bitcoin as
this like you said when you don't have a
party and you're a political you go to
bitcoin and you sort of feel
like you know it's all about freedom and
independence and
um personal responsibility and so on um
but it's interesting so i had rao powell
on the show the other day
and he his opinion is that this freedom
um obviously i hope i've interpreted
this correctly but why from what i
understood
he was sort of saying that it's all a
narrative and
this idea of freedom and you know where
we're independent and with this and with
that and privacy
he sort of said it's just a narrative
and it's not true
it's something that maybe maybe you
could call it propaganda or whatever it
is but it's something that we're playing
into
and regulation's inevitable and that we
will never have this kind of like
um you know utopia this
this utopia whereby you know we're all
free and you know we're exchanging
peer-to-peer and where
did you sort of think that we're
actually going to get to this perfect
future no i mean i i i think i am
somewhere in the middle of that i mean i
agree with
the sentiment of what he's saying but
that doesn't diminish the importance of
what we're doing right um
and it's it's a catch-22 because like if
you want your bitcoin to rise you need
other people that don't know about
bitcoin yet to want to buy it
right so like if all these people were
talking about getting like filthy rich
on bitcoin
you need all those things to happen
regulation is obviously
coming um i don't necessarily think
that's a bad thing i don't think
bitcoin can be banned by any stretch but
like
they can certainly make it really really
difficult to uh
to get your money in and out you know i
think that's the the fear of regulation
that would be worth
having but i mean at the end of the day
it's still the best shot that we have
um no i don't think and also like i
think the bitcoin sort of peer-to-peer
narrative has somewhat died i know that
that's the
white paper you know peer-to-peer cash i
think that
it's been solidified as you know store
of value uh
gold 2.0 and to be quite honest with you
i think a stable coin is a better
peer-to-peer cash than
is it sends faster you get the same
amount that you see
the person receiving it gets the same
amount of money that you sent you know
i don't know if that's a hot take or
controversial but i think that people
want
to hold their bitcoin now and that's
better that's that's what it's for
yeah it shouldn't be a hot take should
it um but but it is because people are
sort of like well stable coins enable
the fiat system you know it enables it
but no i'm totally with you you know you
i mean even
even in terms of like earning passive
income you know you get great interest
on your stable coins it just
i think it it it's all personal it all
depends on what you want um
i definitely see bitcoin as more of a
store of value
i'm totally with you on that so but
unfortunately it is controversial
right but you know as he's saying it's a
part of it will become a part of the
system it'll become regulated but
if you have a true true deep belief in
bitcoin like
you always have that possibility in your
mind that the system fails
yes right so if the entire system fails
bitcoin will become that crazy you know
you well dystopian not utopian but thing
that sort of people
talk about so i think like i said i
think it's both like
they can regulate it to death they can
do all these things they can turn it
into wall street but if wall street
fails and if
central banks fail and if we see
hyperinflation bitcoin will return
to that thing that we're talking about
so i think it's a bit of both right now
the world's not
as much as the world looks like a like a
like it's collapsing it's not the dollar
is not collapsing it's dropping but
we're not seeing hyperinflation all
those things so in the context of the
existing environment now i think he's
correct yeah absolutely i think that's
just a narrative you know um
like like you said even no matter even
if everything does
fail the technology is still there if we
end up in a situation like venezuela
there have been issues in nigeria um you
know if we end up in that kind of
situation then we have bitcoin and we
still have the technology um
but you you are a trader so i want to
know because i actually don't trade um
i mean not not in the way that you do um
but what are the key things you look out
for in a good
trade so like i always sort of go out
there and say that
trading is basically gambling really can
be really fun it can be really
profitable but um just to be clear like
i'm an investor first even though i
trade quote-unquote professionally i
still will only trade with 15
of my capital like sometimes if the
market's really good i'll go up but i'm
generally
at least 50 in long-term investments
15 in cash and like 15 percent
um excuse me 70 investment 15
cash 15 trading so even though i'm a
trader trader
like i don't i'm not dumb enough to do
it with all of my money you know
um and then and historically probably my
investments have done better than my
trades
you know so that's kind of you know just
uh to to be clear there
what i'm looking for like the way i
approach trading
i love charts i love technical analysis
but i have no fallacy that it predicts
the future or
any sort of science right i view
technical analysis as a risk management
tool
just a way for me to justify in my own
mind where i want to buy something
where my idea is invalidated so where to
put my stop loss and where i want to
sell it to take profit
so you can do that in a million ways
right you can like
i don't know sacrifice baby kittens if
it gives you like the
right entry it doesn't matter or you can
use elliott waves or rsi it doesn't
matter
right so i believe in charts as a risk
management tool but at the end of the
day all that matters in trading is being
able to control your emotions and
actually
play out your plan without changing it
in the middle like you have to
let your stop-loss hit like that if
you're if you have to let your stop-loss
hit and you have to actually sell when
you're in profit and not get greedy and
think it's going to go higher and that's
all trading is and
almost nobody can do it i was terrible
at it
do you take um fundamentals into account
um
when you're trading i do now um
and i always did like with stocks since
like when you trade a stock you
buy a stock because you think it's a
good company right so like that's why
crypto was always so fun because
it was like this crazy no fundamental
world where you could just like look at
these charts and trade and things would
go and made you feel like this
genius but in reality you're probably
just there um
but um now i think that the market has
somewhat changed
so i like take less trades and i make
more sort of investments there's all
these you know
opportunities i guess because um i have
a following or
people know me or whatever but pre-sale
opportunities and all these like new d5
projects and stuff
i'm aggressively sort of looking for
opportunities to invest in things really
early
and sort of approach it that way
although like i you know
uh and i think that that long term is
more profitable and that's fully
fundamental
right like if you if you're getting in
before there's even a chart
um or sort of the days that they launch
so like i think
like my investor mode has gone like full
full meth head this year um and you know
trading has
i do it a lot but like trading has taken
largely a back seat because we
like it's not like 2017 where it was
like full
fomo like now i think you can actually
pay attention to the fundamentals of
projects and
listen it's really hard to pay attention
to the fundamentals of old projects that
have bag holders that are down 90
but like new stuff i think there's a lot
of opportunities to find ones that could
really be like
impactful companies you don't have to
answer this but i'm just wondering is
there anything
which um sort of looks interesting to
you there are a lot of new projects this
year
um particularly d5 projects is there
anything that you're looking out for in
there are so many i like there are so
many um
actually today i'm talking a friend of
mine benjamin minshew i don't know if
you're familiar with elrond or
yeah yeah yeah of course yeah about them
like
i love them and i love him i had him on
my podcast many
months ago and i just like believe in
their project so i'm really excited
about what they have and literally like
i'm talking to him today again
been begging him to come back and chat
with me so um really passionate about
them you trust
is a company i really really love yeah
bitcoin is utk
um it's funny i do this what we're doing
right now like i have people on my
podcast and then i become like a super
fanboy
and i get really buying their coins so
that's you know i had sonia khan on but
i've been
uh you know i have a newsletter and
utrust has been working on
figuring out a way to do recurring
crypto payments which nobody's been able
to
ever ever able to do so i've been
working with them for a long time
and something like that uh poco pulpa
starter p-o-l-s is the coin is like one
i'm
really excited about and they actually
their first idea was launched today
mahadow like
there's just so many and like so many of
them are gonna go to complete
like 99 not the ones i'm mentioning i
don't think but like yeah
but i i think that this time like we're
seeing the rug pulls and all that
craziness and that is really sad
and unfortunate but most of these people
are very well intel
well um intentioned people with
brilliant ideas and
some of them are just gonna be
incredible and
most will just fail for whatever various
reasons that these projects fail but
um if you're in a position monetarily to
like throw money at ten of them and
accept that like seven might go to crap
but three of them will make you rich
then godspeed
you know do it i like it i like the
mentality um
yeah i mean people always ask me where
do you see this thing going in ten years
and i'm like well let's say 90 of these
projects won't be here anymore oh i'm
surprised it's
i i thought we'd have seen it already
from a lot
of stuff yeah i mean but they're still
congrats still hanging around
yeah trainers are driving most of that
though yeah that is true that is true
i want to talk about bitcoin because it
is going crazy i think before
um we went live it was and there we go
so it's at 23
500 which is pretty insane i want to get
your thoughts just generally
um on this year bitcoin's performance
you know it dropped in march
uh when all the news came out but then
it sort of just snapped right back
um ahead of everything so did you expect
that and
yeah did you expect that i did um
and i have a long history of tweets to
prove it for anyone who says that i'm
hindsight um whatever
so like i i don't believe that and maybe
unfairly like i've never
particularly turned bearish on bitcoin
there have been times when i shorted it
like as a trader but
you know in general uh not at all so
um march was scary yes
um it was scary and you know
but uh and and so i was like
standing on top of the hill just taking
shots saying that bitcoin was an
uncorrelated asset
and never sort of changed that narrative
and when it all dropped everybody
obviously came after me
like ha ha how's your not correlation
now and you know i try to explain to
people that
in those terrible moments for that one
or two weeks things are horrible
and everything correlates and drops but
we've seen now what bitcoin has done
relative to everything else so
hopefully i found some vindication um in
that but yes i did expect it to come
back so for for two
two reasons first of all i think we had
a
the beginning of that drop in march uh
was uh flight to flight to liquidity
right so
you had like bigger players that had
tried to get exposure you couldn't sell
a bond
right literally there was nobody there
to sell to buy your bonds which is
insane so bigger players had to sell
bitcoin because liquid you can literally
get your cash out of bitcoin anytime any
moment which is a good thing but bad at
that moment
and then you know that may be sent it
from 9000 to 7500 on march 12th
and then there's no question that bitx
destroyed the market
that day their liquidation engine just
started firing like
liquidations of 15 20 30 million dollar
shorts into a mark
and there was no orders to buy them so
price went all the way down to you know
3800 they turned it off or they would
have literally sent it to zero
there was a point on their books where
there was like only 15 million dollars
left from zero to 3 800 in buy orders
right so and that's why we saw it snap
right back to 6
000 like 12 hours later so like i i view
the back half of that entire move
as just the wild west yolo casino that
is bitcoin right and not
something that really was like
fundamental and we've risen
steadily from there you know and there
there was never a doubt in my mind that
we were on our way back i never thought
we'd go to 1000 or 2000
and frankly like i even wrote about this
literally today my newsletter like
there's a very big difference between
the value of
something and the price of something
okay um
and bitcoin especially right i mean if
the value is is really the fundamentally
what something is worth and the price is
what
someone's willing to pay for it at any
given moment right
holders held through all of that they
didn't give a like they knew that
it would rise again
and we're seeing the fundamental value
of bitcoin as a hedge
against inflation as a store of value
all these things
and that has not been reflected in the
price most of this year
and now price is catching up to the
value in my opinion
and you know that that value is real
when you see microstrategy
and john and stanley druckenmiller and
and paul tudor jones and every
billionaire on the planet now
talking the book and saying that uh
they're they're coming in
and that does not happen randomly
they don't buy an asset that does not
have value
and they're not buying it to sell it a
thousand dollars higher
right and that so people and they're
also not buying it if they
have any legitimate fear until that the
government is going to ruin that for
them
you don't think michael saylor has a
friend at the sec who he calls before he
buys
a billion dollars worth of bitcoin give
me a break right damn when you put it
like that scott
these guys are not buying something
that's going to be regulated to zero
it's just not happening
they like goldman's like these jp morgan
these guys they are
the treasury right i mean like it's
it's a revolving door between goldman
sachs and jp morgan and the government
and so you know i think that the value
of bitcoin is much higher i think that
these companies that want it as a
treasury asset that believe that they
need to have exposure to protect their
cash
like it's not even big enough or the
price isn't high enough yet for them to
buy
apple can't put a half percent of their
treasury in bitcoin without buying every
bitcoin on the planet right so like the
market cap needs to be in the trillions
like gold
and they will yeah no i think it's
insane um
you mentioned it was scary someone just
wrote in the comments which i think is
really funny
well it's not funny but i'm happy for
him now so someone writes lol
in march i saw my life savings dropped
50 percent
but i just kept hodling and buying more
good for you kevin
that's conviction and that works as long
as
you know listen isn't it like if you're
an investor that you have belief in
something
yeah you shouldn't even be checking the
value of it yes
you know every day like it should be
like your long-term investment portfolio
should have a 30-40 year timeline and
horizon and you should be looking at it
every six months to see if you need to
like slightly tweak something
i mean i used to so like i used to buy
spy which is
you know like spx basically like i still
do
um monthly you know just dollar cost
averaging it's basically
the best way to just track the stock
market and i started doing this in like
2006 or 2007 when i finally had like a
little money and i could do it
and like immediately we hit this crazy
recession like global recession and it
dropped you know 50
60 whatever it was and like it was just
going in the background i never thought
about it
and then like by 2020 like literally
every single purchase
of spy i'd ever done since 2006 was in
profit
you know and and if you have a long time
horizon like he's talking about
like you're buying those dips that's
what you want to do i i talked to peter
brandt the other day actually you know
the famous trader and he said to me he's
like i tell my kids
that you should buy a company that you
like and hope the price goes down 50
so you can buy more yeah yeah that's
conviction
um that's absolutely conviction like my
my brother i was talking to him about
bitcoin today because i told him to buy
at 10k
and he was like no no i'm gonna wait
till he gets a bit under i was like
it's not going under um and you know
he's asking me now um oh are you going
to sell
he's like you know you should sell and
i'm like no
because what's the point like i i think
it's going to go higher like i think
100k i don't know when
but you know i think 100k i think 400k i
i i think gold 2.0 um
so there's yeah so you know it's so
funny it's like 23k and my brother's
like
why don't you sell and i'm like no it
doesn't make sense so
we've hit new highs we're in price
discovery mode um
tell me what do you think is going to go
what's going to happen i mean a lot of
people are talking
i've had 100k by quarter one or 2021. i
don't know how i feel about that um
what do you think nothing makes you look
like a jackass more than a wild price
prediction that doesn't come true so i
try
very hard not okay because sort of no
but sort of like you're saying
you're not selling it so why does it
matter right like i don't care i mean i
i don't want the price to go down
i don't want to have six thousand dollar
video weekend
anytime dude that would be uh really bad
but um
i think those numbers are in play that's
all i'm saying like i don't know what
the timeline is for that to happen
or when it would happen but um i'd be
very
i mean you know it was what 3 800 i mean
we're up
six seven times already since march like
just double it doubling from here is
almost 50 grand
and percentages percentage moves matter
much more than the fixed number right
that's why like most
traders use logarithmic charts because a
25 000
move uh even let's say a one thousand
dollar move from
nineteen thousand to twenty thousand is
nothing compared to a one thousand
dollar move from two thousand to three
thousand right that's a fifty percent
move
so you get caught up in now these
numbers but the bigger numbers make
sense in the context of percentage
growth
and that's what you're concerned so even
a 2x from here puts us near 50 000 i'd
be very surprised if we didn't do a 2x
from here at some point the next year or
two
but i think the higher targets are in
play like i don't think 300
400 are insane and i will be pretty
disappointed if we don't hit 100 at some
point
yeah of course when do you think the
foam is gonna absolutely come piling in
i say 50k
oh yeah i think like 40 50. i think it's
starting
i'm definitely getting the like and i
just like it's just so funny like i told
people
like i couldn't have screamed louder
like bitcoins
six thousand dollars buy it just buy it
just buy some
and now the same people who didn't want
it now are asking me if they should buy
it at
twenty three thousand dollars i know do
you know what really frustrates me
um it's kind of like so i'm just like
here head down working in the crypto
space like
really just like doing it you know i
guess like you know your career is
gambling on it
um you know my friends are off doing
like pr and medicine and law
and whatever they're doing um and then i
get the call
leia so like you know how how do i buy
bitcoin and i'm like oh
yeah like you don't it's like you you
know you need it you need them to like
come in eventually but also like
those are they start to be top signals
you know so like you just it's like
such a catch 22. like stay out of here
but also we kind of need you like
somebody has to somebody's gonna have to
whenever the top is somebody's gonna
have to buy it right
so yeah i want to get your thoughts on
ethereum um
so i think that touch was it 700
yesterday or just
just under 700 um not really watching a
theorem that much right now but probably
should
um what are your thoughts do you think
that's going to get to um
1k before bitcoin gets to 25.
what are your thoughts i mean
that would be a really bad bet as a
gambler just because that's like almost
a 50
move for ethereum and it's like a couple
percent from here for for bitcoin so no
i mean
even if i thought that like if i was a
gambling man and you gave me odds i
would take uh
bitcoin hitting 25 first but
i think ethereum's gonna perform better
than bitcoin
oh really in the long run or just in
2021 in the coming
months and years i think that uh even
rationally
um you know bitcoin's past its all-time
high and ethereum's at half it's
all-time high so even if it just reaches
an all-time high it's 100 you know it's
a doubling move
um and so i would see that happening uh
largely the d5 boom is happening on
ethereum whether that means ethereum
itself has to go up or not but like
ethereum is being used literally every
single day like if you've ever
been on uniswap or something and paid
gas fees then you definitely know like
ethereum is being used people
need it so there's a legitimate demand
for it
also like we're starting to see sort of
the same
hints of what we saw with bitcoin
earlier this year okay
with institutions with ethereum like
we hear everyone talking about bitcoin
but then all of a sudden like grayscale
last week was like well we're getting a
lot more calls about ethereum than we
are about bitcoin and our ethereum
trust and and greyscale is like not only
have they bought all the
bitcoin that's been mined and more
they've bought more ethereum
than it's been mined and more you know
and that shows that there's real
institutional and
serious demand and i'm trying to think
who it was today
guggenheim okay um you know said that
they want to buy a couple hundred
million and they said in bitcoin
and ethereum evenly
so like i think that and i think that
rationally the same sort of fomo we're
talking about there's people who like
feel like they missed bitcoin who maybe
won't feel like they missed ethereum and
can get it quote unquote cheaper
you know so i think that there's a lot
of things that line up for ethereum to
do very well
and you know and ethereum 2.1 has been
successful
you know they've managed they managed to
well overshoot the amount they needed
staked i just think there's a lot of
bullishness and i don't think you have
to like choose one or the other i think
it's fine to like both
i don't view ethereum as a store of
value
ethereum is digital gold i view it as a
great platform that that
has a chance to grow and and appreciate
and so
it's like that whole like hatred of the
two communities is so weird to me it's
like
can you imagine like all the people who
love tesla just being super pissed at
everyone who likes amazon
yeah i mean so okay two things here so
firstly
the ceo of old coinbase once said to me
so his name's shash i think he's
amazing he once said to me that um
ethereum is
the amazon it is amazon and
bitcoin is gold and i just love that
comparison i thought it was amazing
um that's even better yeah yeah i think
it's great okay so like tribalism right
there's like huge inner space and i
think i tweeted a few
months ago something like imagine not
liking somebody because they prefer a
different coin to you
and holy like that blew up and
you know i had adam back in the comments
writing stuff calling things like
ethereum a scam
um i think maybe he called cosmos a scam
um
and ponzi schemes or whatever so
why do people just like really hate on
ethereum you know we're having a really
normal conversation right now
why are we not able to do this why why
is it bitcoin only why can't ethereum
you know be something different in its
own in its own right
i don't know um well no i mean i
i i it's a symptom of a larger problem
like in life and we've talked about it
already a bit like people are just try
tribalism is the norm right it's like my
team
my country my religion my
town my my you know whatever it is like
people just they like to like root for
theirs and there's people who are very
early on bitcoin and
i don't know if they see it as a threat
or they just view like everything else
as a distraction or what it is but like
to outwardly call something that's
successful and
has positive elements like a scam or
something it's just
i mean it's just it doesn't make sense
and
to me that's like uh it's like showing
your hand that you're like an
overly emotional just sort of like yeah
disheveled
human person you know um like why do you
care
even if you like really don't like it
maybe just like ignore it
like just stuff that i really like don't
like or agree with i generally just
ignore
like i don't spend my my energy on
negativity towards something that
doesn't affect my life
and i think that like there's it's just
really like
it's really crazy and the and the and
the up thing is that like if
everybody just
stopped doing that like they would all
get so much richer
like because if everybody just worked
together and was like generally positive
about crypto as a whole we're way too
small to be like fighting amongst
ourselves you know so if everybody who
had a passion for any project or crypto
or whatever
was just sort of like you know a rising
tide lifts all boats
and said hey if ethereum does great
today that's awesome because it brings
more attention and
you know my link will eventually rise or
whatever it is
i think that we would get where we're
looking to go so much so much faster
because people are just really emotional
and they're just like it's a it's a it's
a matter of being right and wrong
and which doesn't really matter right
yeah i i think it's an interesting one
um i think
um you know if you say something like
that you know you say something like we
should
um call these things out because they're
scams and i i wholeheartedly believe
they're scams and i think that's immoral
um you know if the it's kind of like a
social justice warrior kind of thing
because it's like well hang on you're
not following through if you're such a
moral person and
you want to protect people there are a
lot of you know far more
um awful injustices going on in the
world so like you could focus on that
you know if it was if it really came
from such a pure
and moral place you know which is like i
don't want to get
if i don't get too much into politics
but that's kind of like the situation in
politics with social justice warriors
are like
talking about like microaggressions and
all this stuff when you have like actual
genocide going on which they're not
interested in
in talking about which kind of i don't
know some synergies i guess
um yeah yeah i mean yeah i mean if you
ever needed an example of
that which kind of like when we're
talking about like changing your
politics or whatever like
everybody stay inside but it's totally
cool to write
come on right i mean so we see examples
of that kind of thing
um all the time and i agree with you i
think it's just like
it's not their real feeling it's just
like a
emotional reaction to something that
they've
it's just being triggered like why does
ethereum trigger you if you like bitcoin
like why mm-hmm
no i wouldn't do it with you it's funny
um i have a few interesting topics i
want to go through um
still before before we head to the end
one which i want to touch on
is ross um albrecht i don't know how to
pronounce his name properly
exactly yeah for us yeah
so let's talk about that because you
know
trump has come to the end of his
presidency people say you know he he's
pardoning um he's pardoned some people
are ready
um he said he's not going to pardon
edward snowden um
he sort of went hard on that i was like
no he did this he did that
what are your thoughts um on free ross i
know a lot of people in the community
aren't actually all forfeiting ross i'm
i'm all for free and ross yeah um
i had a long talk with his mom so maybe
i'm like biased because she's like the
sweetest woman in the world and just
like
wants clemency for her son but um
first of all even if ross was guilty of
every single thing that they say he's
guilty of
he got two life sentences plus like 40
years
right uh like el chapo didn't even like
get
a full life sentence or something like
literal and what's crazy
is that the people like a silk road 2
was started by people who were like
legitimate criminals and drug dealers
and stuff and got busted and got like
short sentences
so like just the disproportionate
punishment
so like i think ross probably should
have gone to jail
yeah maybe like i don't you know i don't
know the ins and outs i don't believe he
was hiring hitmen to kill people and all
that kind of stuff but like
you know i think he had he was very
idealistic like believed in libertarian
things and
tried to do something good but maybe he
broke the law some doing it and maybe
deserved to go to jail for a while
it's enough like two and a half life
sentences
for uh letting some people buy weed on
the internet
it's just absurd and you know like
there's just these times when one person
is
becomes the example for whatever reason
he took a fall for like
yes the entire like the entire system
the entire
entire space whatever and like it's
enough like or
tell the guy he has to stay for five
more years and then let him out you know
what i mean i don't know what the just
punishment is but i know that it's not
too lifetime he didn't kill anyone
and they can't even prove that anyone
like was hurt or died from anything that
he allowed
you know and a lot of things that they
say were it was just drugs you know and
like whatever it's not like people were
selling children and and
weapons of mass destruction all the
things that people rumored that was
happening that's not what was happening
so i think yeah absolutely i think it
would be an amazing move by trump to
free him
and if he doesn't i hope biden does
to be honest you know it's really funny
i don't think biden could care less
um that's just my opinion on biden i
think he's you know without getting too
into but i think he's an absolute fake
um i don't think he's uh i think he's a
bit of a fake to be honest but
i think you make a really interesting
point um you know as a libertarian
myself
i'm still very much like i'm living in a
civil society follow the laws of the
land
um but absolutely you know two life
sentences plus whatever you know
i think rape people that actually rape
you know rape charges are less than that
um and in my opinion that's one of the
worst things charges are sometimes a
slap on the
slap on the wrist and like uh listed on
a website or something you know what i
mean like
there are people just doing far far
worse things so yeah like you said to me
it's the disproportionate punishment
that does not fit the crime that is
really the biggest problem like i i
can't really
not a legal scholar like i don't know
the level to which he committed a crime
or not i've never
dug in but i know that whatever crime he
committed doesn't deserve the punishment
yeah and i think you make an interesting
point as well that it i think they were
setting an example
of him yeah they said yeah they did
because something was
they knew something was brewing
something brewed you know bitcoin is
here
um and you know setting an example
um but if he started it like now he
wouldn't have even gotten in so much
trouble there's also
absolutely the world just wasn't ready
for it it's sad
yeah absolutely and speaking of the
world being ready for things i want to
get your thoughts um just as you come to
the end of this on mass adoption
um you know what what are we missing
when it when will it happen
you know we talk a lot about user
experience but i'm hearing other things
in terms of like
regulation and taxes and kind of just
like the logistics
um being difficult yeah it's hard
because it depends on how you
like define mainstream adoption there's
people who are like bitcoin becomes the
global currency and it's the only thing
we transact in well if that's what
you're waiting for we never get
mainstream adoption
right because i don't think that that's
going to happen but if by mainstream
adoption we mean a
asset that's respected and viewed like
any other asset that can be traded
legally with protections i think that's
here
like we're within months i think more
than months of what maybe you'd call
mainstream adoption
um you know like
to me almost at this point when you're
looking at mainstream adoption would be
like more people using
usdc than paypal to send their money you
know or like
like things like that that um have not
happened yet
and maybe will but like i don't think
it's going to replace the whole system
but i think that it can be normalized
within the system and still have its
importance to those of us who are like
really passionate about it in the
community and to me that would be enough
mainstream adoption but like when you
have billionaires putting it
in you know buying it with their cash
reserve their company that's
pretty mainstream i i think you're
trying to hear
i think we're kind of here i think that
there's levels to it but i think that
we've started
maybe maybe it's fair to say that we're
for the first time we're scratching the
surface of mainstream adoption
yes that i can i can definitely agree
with you on i want to get to the point
where i work with a guy
in um brazil who um isn't in crypto
but he edits some videos for me found
him through twitter he's a great guy um
but we've got to pay him through paypal
and it's really annoying
um and there's just no like his english
isn't amazing like
there's no way i can sit down with him
over zoom and be like here's how you
open up a wallet like let me pay him a
bit like
no well for i mean
central bank digital currencies are an
inevitability
so very soon whether you like it or not
everyone in the world pretty much is
going to learn to transact
digitally through a wallet right that
might be two or three years away but um
that is inevitable well that's good and
you think it'll be the same thing
do you think it'll be like done the same
way with the wallet and the address and
do you think it'd be done like that i
think it'll be more simplistic than that
but i do think that you will have like a
wallet on your phone and you will like
tap whether a qr code or something else
to send and receive a digital
transaction and once we have that level
of understanding i mean if you go to
china everybody knows how to do that
right
i want to spread that around the world i
think that um
you know that'll only be good for for
bitcoin and stuff because i like
if i'm given the option to pay with a
digital dollar or with
like some crypto currency especially if
it has privacy aspects i'm certainly
going to
choose the latter even though the first
one is is easy so
i i think that what you're talking about
is just a matter of time
but i really believe it's inevitable
whether it's with a stablecoin or some
other digital currency like
also like you can't microtransact across
borders with any legacy system try
wiring like 20 bucks to somebody in
africa
you'll pay 20 bucks on your end they'll
pay 20 bucks and the 20 bucks might
arrive seven months
later you know it's just that it can't
be done so
especially for those lower end
transactions crypto really is the only
answer i'm not saying that's bitcoin
bitcoin's kind of clunky for that but
yeah i'm taking with you i um i took a
trip
to asia quite a few years ago i was in
cambodia and i remember
the the cat he's not a cab driver he was
a truck driver
he um we paid him 15
for the entire week and for him that was
so much money right so if we understand
that
um if we understand you know what's
minimum wage or whatever what's normal
in that country
um and let's say we were supposed to
work with he's gonna do some work with
me across borders
i couldn't you know i wouldn't be able
to pay him whatever
whatever the wage is over there you know
um
so i i think it's i think it's
incredible that we're actually able to
put people on the financial map for me
that was actually my my like my um my
red pill moment
not so much bitcoin it was more like
blockchain putting people on the
financial map
um for me because i'm all about social
good i love a good social good
uh project so yeah yeah so do i
hence why i leaned left as a kid right
it was all about like social justice and
helping people
and stuff and i still believe in all
those things um
but yeah i mean most of the world is
unbanked
right even in a lot of uh even in a lot
of established countries
um you know six or seven out of ten
people don't have a bank account or
access to banking and stuff and that's
just stupid so
like the goal now shouldn't be to get
those people banked
yeah it should be to to skip use this to
just skip it
right like if you go to like that i you
know if you talk to any
american soldiers a friend of mine um
andrew who was the ceo of a company
called roundly x
like he was in afghanistan you know
in the united states military and he was
like we couldn't get running water
we couldn't get electricity but there
was a cell phone store
like in every village you know so like
all you need is a mobile tower and
crypto is accessible to everybody
in the world right cheap phone whatever
and so like
skip the at this point you don't think
about getting people banked you just
think about circumventing that system
altogether
yeah i love it you know it just
absolutely skipping
um financial revolutions really um
i i think it's incredible i love
watching it um but i want to thank you
so much for coming on before we say
goodbye
where can people find you just promote
yourself you've you know
okay you've got a newsletter just tell
us everything
sure i'm the worst self-promoter in the
world that's what tanked my music career
but um
you can find me on you can find me on
twitter at scottmelker
s-c-o-t-t-m-e-l-k-e-r
and you can find the information for
everything else there i have a youtube
channel which i've just pretty much
started in the last couple months and
it's been really really fun i just love
talking and live streaming
um and trolling the people in my
comments um the newsletter
you can find the link to that it's on
it's get review slash the wolf dead and
then my podcast which is also on my
youtube and
you know spotify apple everywhere else
the the wolf of all streets podcast
those are the main things that i do that
keep me extremely
busy but at the core of it of course is
twitter so if you find me at scott
milker you'll
find a very quick uh breadcrumb trail to
everything else that i've got my hands
in
sounds great scott thank you so much
thank you everyone for
watching thank you to iconplus for
powering it blockfy and coinfit for
sponsoring it guys we'll see you
next thursday 12 p.m est bye